all right that's right folks it's the
remake that no one really asked for
poltergeists so poltergeist is a remake
of the 1982 classic haunting movie
poltergeist I know there's gonna be a
lot of poltergeist parallax I was like
my favorite haunting movie of all time
how dead but everything else has been
remade so we'll see how this one goes it
revolves around a family and a lot of
really pissed-off spirits that have
formed an entity of a poltergeist as for
the actors in the movie I really like
Sam Rockwell as the dad he's kind of a
big manchild who's down on his luck he's
out of a job but he just still just kind
of tries to laugh it off he can tell
he's hurt and anxiety and the other
people in the movie I don't know their
names they were functional a couple of
them were good a couple of them were
kids I like Jared Harris in his movie I
like Jared Harris and most things he's
in but he plays the demonologist he's
like the expert is like all right I'm
gonna get your daughter back from the
evil CGI ghouls in the closet and the TV
and all it's a weird feeling watching
this movie because poltergeist was this
original thing when it came out and this
remake tries to recreate the iconic
moments in poltergeist only thing is
they're now no longer original concepts
so it's just like it looks like a bunch
of rehash [ __ ] the poltergeist comes out
in the 80s and it's this really
revolutionary thing you know this
original concept - over the course of
the next three decades haunting movies
and scary movies they try to pull from
poltergeist Eltham utley borrow bits and
pieces of it so now poltergeist is
remade in 2015 and there's just
everything in here has been seen many
many many times do you ultimately have
this movie that's just kind of yeah
you've seen it a lot that's not to say
the movies not entertaining there were
some entertaining ass parts there was
actually one scene involving shadows I
loved that scene it was the scene that
made me feel like the most imagination
was put into it which is really cool to
see I wish there were more scenes
dealing with shadows because shadows
just freak me out is that one episode of
Star Trek The Next Generation where
there was that shadow and Geordi found
out in the holodeck he was like whoa
whose shadow was that and it felt like
something was watching you the entire
time it scared me ever since then
shadows are frightening but it's like at
a point in this movie it accepts the
fact that it's not going to recapture
the fright that the original poltergeist
had so it just CGI's it was this big
portal and just electricity coming out
of it and I was like well a lot of
special effects in this movie you even
see a lot of like ghoulish ghostly
things
that looks CG I was like that looks bit
like a video again I'm not gonna lie to
you guys I walked out of this movie
going yeah I was entertained in the
movie but nothing in the movie was
frightening nothing gave me chills
nothing actually creeped me out even the
clown scene didn't scare me because you
saw the jump scare of it in the trailer
yeah there are a few jump scares in this
movie that always irritates the [ __ ] out
of me so you have jump scares and a lot
of special effects and neither of those
are really scary to me the fact that
nothing in this movie really scared me
it all means the movie although
entertaining did fail so what's right on
the cusp of entertainment for me but I'm
gonna go ahead and knock it a step down
and say poltergeist would probably be a
good time if you're drunk ya know it's a
party to hear further part hi guys so
poltergeist have you seen it what did
you think about it you could take it for
this or the original poltergeist
whatever you want to answer whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you